[Musik]
Bild breaking news
ja diese Meldung hat uns gerade erreicht
es gibt eine Razzia bei Melanie Müller
seit dem frühen Morgenstunden durchsucht
die Polizei das Wohnhaus der
ballermann-sängerin in Leipzig
Hintergrund sind Ermittlungen des
Staatsschutzes zu diesen Videos sie
sehen es hier selber da sehen wir ein
Konzert von Melanie Müller ja und ihre
Besucher die fangen an Sieg Heil zu
brüllen dann zeigt sehen wir die
Sängerin wie sie dann tatsächlich
weitermacht und auch ihren rechten Arm
nach oben stößt und ja eben
auch einheizt ein wenig jetzt muss eben
der Staatsschutz entscheiden wie man
tatsächlich mit diesen Videos umgeht
jetzt Reporter Jerome Nussbaum nach
Leipzig Größe dich Jerome was glaubt die
Polizei denn da finden zu können oder
hat sie möglicherweise gefunden bei
Melanie Müller
ja seit 5 Uhr sind hier Polizisten im
Einsatz an ihren Privathaus sie selbst
ist nicht da auf Mallorca aber ihren
Freund haben wir getroffen den Andreas
Kunst er sagte uns man hat hier nach
Speichermedien gesucht also es geht
offensichtlich darum dass die Polizei
sicherstellen will ob sie wirklich in
einer Verbindung steht zu den Rowdys
Eastside wo ja dieser Auftritt
stattgefunden hat bei dem sie den
Hitlergruß gemacht haben soll sie
behauptete diese Leute dort überhaupt
nicht bekannt zu haben oder überhaupt
nicht gewusst zu haben vor welchen
Menschen sie da Auftritte sollen ja
Hooligans von Fußballclubs wie auch
immer gewesen sein eine Motorradgang
Walker das versucht man wahrscheinlich
zu klären ob es noch mehr Beweismaterial
gibt ob es Verbindung gibt ob sie
vielleicht auch bei anderen Auftritten
den Hitlergruß gezeigt hat oder ähnlich
rechtsgerichtete Dinge ist Melanie
Müller denn in der Vergangenheit
irgendwie schon mal in dieser Richtung
aufgefallen
nein das ist die nächste bestreite das
auch selbst jedes Mal als rechtsradikal
gewesen zu sein sie verkehrt natürlich
in Kreisen in rockerkreisen mit
Türstehern da kennt man sich
untereinander auch mit Boxern das wurde
sie auch schon wurde ihr vorgeworfen
dass das ja alles irgendwie in die
rechte Richtung geht aber sie selbst
distanziert sich davon sehen ist auch in
der Queen Szene sehr aktiv hat auch ein
Song rausgebracht für die Schwulen und
Lesbenszene das heißt das passt ja
eigentlich gar nicht zusammen dass man
da rechtsradikal sein kann trotzdem hat
sie sich offensichtlich bei diesem
Auftritt um den es geht am 17 September
mitreißen lassen von die Publikum von
dem er auch mehrmals die sie heiruf
bekam mitreißen lassen mit dem
Hitlergruß also das ist ja nichts wo man
sich so hinreißen lässt bei irgendeinem
Konzert Jerome jetzt stehst du da immer
noch wir sehen die Polizei hinter dir du
hast gerade gesagt Melanie Müller ist
gar nicht da die ist auf Mallorca das
heißt die erfährt jetzt möglicherweise
über Bild live dass da bei ihr zu Hause
gerade durchsucht wird
ja sie hatte die letzten Nächte immer
noch Auftritte im Oberbayern Club
wahrscheinlich wird sie aber von ihrem
Lebensgefährten Andreas Kunz erfahren
haben was hier los ist er selbst sagte
uns er wurde 5 Uhr ungefähr geweckt
dadurch dass ein Hund gebellt hat die
Polizei stand dann auch schon im Haus
und hat angefangen mit der Arbeit er
wird sie sicherlich informiert haben
dass sie etwas im Gange ist und sie
wusste wahrscheinlich auch Bescheid weil
die Ermittlungen gegen sie sind
offiziell bekannt Jerome Nussbaum du
wirst das Ganze weiter für uns
beobachten danke für den Moment
[Musik]